the ground McNulty squad will have total
command and you will do whatever they
tell you they need to take a piss you
take a knee
and cup your hand this is what I look
like when I clean up mmm today's the
premiere for rush the whole thing the
whole thing we're gonna go over and
watch the entire series you nervous
no we've released so many videos at this
point this is just like a really long
one I'm nervous I think it's gonna be
good but it looks pretty good a car
comes at 5:15 we'll take us to the red
carpet where Sam are going to do some
interviews and then probably for picture
savings I hope I don't see a shot Mike
that's not a finished effect shot and
then here's is a solid chance of that
happening once there's a there's a 99%
chance 99% chance yeah hopefully the
piece moves so fast people forget about
it but only people working on projects
yeah here we go here we go here we are
we are about out in Russia I got my wife
I got my best medicine whatever wants
you pretty excited I saw a super super
early rough cut several months ago I'm
excited to the final thing I'm excited
to see Sam and Nico in their element I
hope they give a speech do you not going
to give a speech you guys feel famous
yet again there is the famous levels are
rising quickly
[Music]
it's the composer the musician over here
over here is all talking how you guys
feeling thirty point one surround sound
51 here's more finally anyways my mind's
blown this one really just delighted to
see everyone there Michael that's kind
of a monumental thing with a large game
company handed over the keys to their
kingdom of the favorite franchise two
talented young filmmakers come from the
internet I don't think that's ever been
done before want to also say thanks to
our friends at Verizon because none of
this would have been everybody thank you
so much for coming out this was quite
the adventure shooting this everybody
committed everything they had in this
piece and it definitely shows in the
final product this was the biggest
project ever done by far and it was just
an incredible ride through through just
brightening everyone here especially
you've you've gotta finish come on
you're from Detroit get cheered up
lastly of to thank my wife Sarah because
we got married
just days before we went out to Detroit
so she didn't deal with me being gone
for two months so I happened
[Applause]
movies debate hold on hey tail
great I've came out amazing everything
came together really well I'm proud of
everybody there's a collective effort
after you walk to meet your husband came
and I haven't met him well yeah but the
Sun was up standing trying to tell him
his Rachel wants me
it's on yeah now there's episode coming
every week 10 meters long will will
everyone be excited happy rewarded yes
will this camera ever get in focus now
what I'm gonna party is awesome -
Bridget amazing job as they always do is
for outstanding score I did I just love
the old battlefield references I was
blown away I almost thought I was in the
wrong movies like can't be this good
ah SIOC we're getting
through it I was
and I got
[Applause]
check it out go 90 dot-com rush inspired
by battle